[Music]
in this morning Saturday sessions the
genre-bending sounds of Beirut's born
out of a teenagers New Mexico bedroom
the band's fifth full-length album
Gallipoli has just been released they'll
perform songs from it in a moment but
first my conversation with the band's
frontman Zac Condon this week here in
New York the music of Beirut can read
like a travel atlas the band's
mastermind Zac Condon has written songs
called Bratislava Brandenburg and
postcards from Italy
there's kind of like a wonder lust in
your music and in the titles of your
song yeah you know sometimes I catch
some flack for that it's hard to title
songs and I used to have this map
sitting over the computer that I was
recording on at the time and I would
just kind of point in fact condon grew
up in Santa Fe and rarely traveled but
as a teenager a job in a movie theater
allowed him to escape it was kind of
like an after-school job you know 525 an
hour
sweep up the popcorn but you liked it
obviously I mean it had its perks I
hated it but I loved the cinema the
theater showed foreign films and the
foreign sounds got under his skin and I
just kind of remember having this
thought around the age of 15 which was
essentially like there is this entire
world of sound out there that we just
seemed to be skipping right over and it
kind of drove me nuts Condon began to
collect exotic instruments and to record
at home you wrote your first album
pretty much in your bedroom in Santa Fe
yeah yeah and that's what you hear on it
too in the beginning where you're
essentially just making this for
yourself oh yeah absolutely yeah I was
too shy to put it out there essentially
someone heard it sent it to a label and
then it kind of ended up online and
people really liked it and I was shocked
did you appreciate that your music was
being appreciated oh yeah I mean that's
incredibly gratifying and it's also nice
because then you know that you're not
crazy yeah you know
but then Condon had to take his music
out of his studio and onto the road it
wasn't always easy yeah there were
periods where it got really hard for me
I've had kind of I've had some crash and
burn moments and tour when you crashed
it burned what what basically caused
that not listening to your body or mind
and agreeing to do more than
you know you can do it's the situation
where people want to see you in in
Brazil and Australia and Japan and you
just can't believe that they do and so
you want to give everything all the time
it's pretty exciting to people want to
see you around the world yeah
[Music]
and Condon has become a citizen of the
world moving to New York then Istanbul
and now Berlin so the travel on your
records it's all coming true in a weird
ways it has become reality
absolutely which you know yeah I stopped
to thinking about from time to time I'm
like oh sometimes I wish I could go back
and tell my 15 year old self that you
know these things these big ambitions
these big dreams they're gonna work out
you know